[Music]
this is iPhone City a Foxconn
manufacturing campus in jeongzhou China
with a population of as much as three
hundred thousand the size of Pittsburgh
the facility at one point made 85
percent of the pro lineup of iPhones but
now that's starting to change other
Foxconn factories like this one in
Southern India have been tapped to build
iPhones and Facilities like this one in
Vietnam are expanding to produce other
products that were once mainly made in
China
that's because protests at the junction
Factory a wave of infections and three
years of coveted woes in China have
helped Propel Apple to look for
Alternatives but supply chain analysts
say China's finely tuned production
system won't be easy to replace so
here's why apple and its suppliers face
an uphill battle when it comes to
building new iPhone cities in India and
Vietnam
over the past two decades Apple has
looked primarily to Foxconn the world's
biggest Electronics manufacturing
company to turn its product designs into
reality since it first began making
iPhones in 2010 foxconn's facility in
Zhengzhou has stood out for its
efficient ecosystem
it excels at collecting the hundreds of
required parts from manufacturers and
assembling the functioning devices to be
shipped out to customers supply chain
analysts say China has been the best at
this because many of these parts and the
metals needed to make them are refined
and built within the country but
assembly plants in India and Vietnam
won't have such easy access to these
components according to its latest list
of suppliers Apple works with more than
180 companies and about 150 have
operations in China just compare that to
Vietnam where only 26 Apple suppliers
have operations while India only has 11.
that means assemblers in these countries
would have to import more of the parts
needed to make Apple products a process
with plenty of paper work and delays
once the parts arrive factories need a
lot of workers to assemble the many
components that go into Apple products
to maintain having hundreds of thousands
of workers in iPhone City in Zhengzhou
foxcom provides on-site accommodation
that has allowed workers from all around
the country to live and work at the
factory
but India's Foxconn Factory where apple
is now building new iPhones from the
beginning of their production cycle is
much smaller with fewer workers so the
company buses them in from nearby
hostels and Villages that are mostly
within a 50 mile radius
analysts say to meet this increasing
demand Fox Combs Factory in India may
eventually need the type of on-campus
accommodation seen in jeongzhou
apple and Foxconn did not respond to
requests for comment about the
challenges facing facilities in India
and Vietnam such as import delays and
Workforce shortages
in Apple's April earnings call CEO Tim
Cook said the company's continuing to
optimize the production process our
supply chain is truly Global and so the
products are made everywhere even though
apple is starting to look elsewhere
analysts say it's unlikely to completely
leave China's efficient system anytime
soon production started to recover after
Foxconn lifted covid-19 restrictions at
its jungju plant in early December and
wait times for high-end iPhone models
have improved
still people involved in Apple's supply
chain say the company may look to other
suppliers within China to reduce its
Reliance on Foxconn
that may mean in the future a wider
range of companies will be building more
of our iPhones and other Apple products